yeah do it photos today we have you rose
us I mean we went through a whole bunch
of them are in fact or Lexi went through
a whole bunch of them and she picked
three the top third photograph in our
sack is great photos you traitorous son
nationally empty trading tour at the new
york stock exchange after trading was
halted due to a quote technical glitch
one stressed-out trader waits for
trading to resume after the
unprecedented shutdown so exactly the
wolf of Wall Street but Tom did you know
about this there's this is a this is a
party venue that you can rent out I'm
downtown so are you really you guys are
great speeches they're up in their
lovely boardroom from another time and
place it's great I love it I I talk to
Duncan Niederauer about this over the
years a former head of this force it is
an iconic place 223 years old it's a
mission under the Buttonwood tree do
they have one in London a stock exchange
I believe that's where it may it started
in Tokyo do they have you know TV set I
you know no it's all electronic all
right we're gonna move on to our second
top photo ebays hot deals for hot days
truck was spotted in New York City
yesterday it gives shoppers hot deals a
must-have items tied to the weather like
for example sunglasses and the holder of
the temperatures the hotter the deals 85
degrees shoppers get eighty five percent
off Amazon isn't missing out on the
opportunity either its treasure truck is
nearing the streets of Seattle filled
with in demand limited quantity products
on sale for that day only so the box of
light bulbs I just got from Amazon where
the light bulbs don't fit cuz of my
fault can I take them back to the
treasure it was just in there take him
back to the truck go back to the talk
and just handed it to them I do like the
discount tied to the actual temperature
because literally indicator that
surrounded yeah the only indicator that
changes sort of in my in my life is that
the hotter it gets the closer the dog
sits to the window unit air conditioned
Michael Purvis with Weeden where this
amazon has just been life-changing for
everybody out there do you see that
forward as retail continue to struggle
right yeah order I mean I think it
should it's percentage of you know
online shopping as percentage of overall
retail sales still not that big
and probably going to continue to tune
you to grow and that's going to be one
of these secular trends that every
retailer you know every you walk into a
lot of these stores or glorified vending
machines in fact walgreens has said that
that they're going to be concentrating
very much on it we've earnings on them
later yeah a little oil seven a.m.
Eastern do out number one top photo
ESPN's body issue comes out today by the
end of this please I was gonna say it
does not feature Tom keen unit features
the best bodies in the world in action
and in the nude and is intended to rival
sports illustrated swimsuit issue the
body issues thirty-three percent higher
readership than the average issue
Washington Nationals outfielder Bryce
Harper heptathlete Shante McMillan and
Giants wide receiver Odell Beckham jr.
are featured this just really well right
I mean seriously mean you got the Sports
Illustrated silliness and then this is a
little more it's like looking at
sculptures yeah it is yeah Rodon yeah
yeah it's pretty amazing sweet Venus
Williams i should say it's but it's a
classy swimsuit issue it's an arty
swimsuit issue yep alright that's all
we're gonna say good shape hey by the
way in the bottom of you and I'm like
can we bring up Bryce Harper again can
we bring up februari can we show him
somebody knew that the server
demonstrated issue comes out in February
yeah um but all of this he says I gotta
get in shape come sure you and I are not
gonna get there right that is not gonna
happen hey Polly pod I think I think you
might be a nine or a ten somebody had
okay